for years in the Western world it was
thought to be blasphemous to build
higher than a church spire the stories
of the Old Testament warned against
reaching too close to the heavens the
builders of the Tower of Babel declared
calm that is build a city and a tower
but it stopped in the heavens and let us
make a name for ourselves lest we be
scattered upon the face of the whole
earth
but God punished them for building a
monument to humanity and not to God by
confusing their language so they could
no longer work together this story is
used as a source of our world's
languages for the religious and some
still use it as an argument against
their modern world but it has
interesting undertones for the
development of our cities for centuries
the church spire remained as the focal
point of most Western cities the Trinity
Church was the largest building in New
York until 1890 when the New York world
building was completed this marked an
end to the Cathedral dominated skylines
of many cities across the world those
church spires served as a symbol of
piety but the New York world buildings
height allowed Joseph Pulitzer to expand
his growing business without having to
find a large swathe of land on the
outskirts of the city growing taller
served a practical purpose and it still
does in many cases it's that the man for
space that truly drives up the average
height of buildings and cities cities
like Hong Kong do not have any super
tall buildings but the average height of
buildings in Hong Kong is among the
highest in the world that is largely
driven by the lack of space available
Hong Kong is confined by the sea on one
side and the Chinese border on the other
while having a very mountainous
landscape there isn't a huge amount of
land to build on this fourth buildings
to grow taller to accommodate the city's
population when Hong Kong needed to
expand their international airport there
is little space available instead they
decided to level two islands outside the
city to create a new artificial island
where the new airport is now located
this project added one percent to the
total surface area of Hong Kong when
space is limited
humans are forced to get inventive to
cope but in many cities across the world
is not an issue and these cities usually
decide to expand outward
this is called urban sprawl and it's
been a topic of debate lately but calls
to stop this decentralization of cities
urban sprawl requires little
micromanagement of resources you simply
continue to expand current utilities and
roads and approve buildings and cheaper
undeveloped land it's an easy solution
to a growing population but it creates
many problems of its own and is
completely unsustainable as populations
grow you cannot simply keep expanding
the city and allowing these problems to
escalate it has huge environmental and
social impacts one of the most obvious
which my friend went over productions
spoke about in his last video was an
increasing commute time with an
increasing city diameter the distances
we have to cover to reach the city
center increases and it is incredibly
difficult to serve all of these
far-flung suburban neighborhoods with
adequate public transport this results
in a city dependent on the care our
least efficient form of transport this
not only has social impacts as a long
commute is one of the highest and most
controllable factors that affect our
happiness but the average American
spends 17600 minutes behind the wheel a
year much of that is spent in gridlocked
traffic that's equivalent to spending
almost an extra 37 days at your
traditional eight hour nine-to-five job
but it also has a direct impact on
pollution and air quality in the city -
that's 17,600 minutes of a car polluting
the environment reducing our city's
dependence on cars reduces our carbon
footprint on this world urban sprawl
affects our cities in other ways too
spreading our cities creates water
distribution problems here in Ireland it
is thought that up to 50 percent of the
treated water is lost through pipe
leaking the problem is not unique to
Ireland in 2010 it was reported that 3.3
billion litres of water was wasted in
England and Wales - pipe leakage
reducing sprawl reduces the length of
pipes needed and thus reduces the
chances of leakages the problem can be
attenuated further by creating buildings
with self-sustaining water supplies this
is becoming a growing trend in
consideration among engineers lead or
Leadership in Energy and Environmental
Design is one of the most popular green
building certifications used worldwide
it rates how resource efficient
buildings are in their construction
energy use and water use the Taipei 101
was awarded Lee's heister
education with a platinum certificate it
achieved this with its own dedicated
water management systems and low-flow
water fixtures this design ideology
helped the Taipei 101 to decrease its
potable water consumption by at least 30
percent compared to the average building
consumption saving about 28 million
litres of potable water annually when
you also consider that in America
landscape irrigation is estimated to
account for nearly one third of all
residential water use totaling nearly
nine billion gallons of water per day it
would be vastly more sustainable for a
world where water is an ever increasing
demand to create cities where we have a
larger percentage of lead certified
high-rise residential buildings this
goes beyond just environmental impacts
there are a number of socio-economic
motivations to creating more high-rise
buildings - I pointed out that urban
sprawl results in longer commute times
and the roads and public transportation
needed to facilitate those commutes are
not free they need to be maintained and
built with your tax money and while
building up is more costly the cost and
risk is usually incurred on a private
contractor and the costs of building up
starts to decline once you reach a
certain height to build a skyscraper
there are a number of fixed costs but
many of these costs do not increase with
the height of the building fix costs
like the cost of land legal fees and
design costs can be offset by building
higher if the building is built on a
hundred square meter plot of land and
the building has 40 stories each floor
only takes up 2.5 square meters of land
that has obvious economic advantages
especially when you consider design a
material costs only start to go up when
you reach around the 40th floor and that
critical height is likely to go up as
technology improves buildings like the
Burj Khalifa may just be exuberant
displays of wealth but they do serve as
technology demonstrators for 25 years
the tallest building in the world was a
Sears Tower now known as the Willis
Tower it uses a bundled tube structure
which maximizes the amount of floor
space but if we scale this building to
the size of the Burj Khalifa its floor
space would be dominated by structural
elements and the interior would have no
natural light as mentioned in my last
video the buttress core of the Burj
Kalifa provides structural integrity
needed to reach those Heights while
maximizing both the window access and
usable space
this is vital knowledge and experience
to have to allow building Heights to
keep growing while keeping costs down so
you may be thinking why aren't there
more high-rise buildings if there are
all these benefits there must be reasons
why we aren't building more of them we
will learn why after this quick sidenote
a lot of you have been admiring the
footage I use in my videos and most of
it comes from videoblocks com who have
kindly sponsored this video video blocks
has one of the largest stock video
libraries on the web with over two
million stock videos after effects and
motion backgrounds with the video blocks
membership you get access to over two
million clips for 40% off per clip
compared to competitors sites and over a
hundred thousand clips are included for
free with your membership - I get to use
these videos with a hundred percent
royalty-free agreement that means I can
make money from my videos which has
allowed me to make this channel my
full-time job without worry of
infringing any copyrights membership is
usually 149 dollars per year but video
box is offering an exclusive $50
discount if you go to videoblocks com4
slash holidays or click on the link in
the description below so the primary
reasons we aren't building higher is
because of City Planning and regulatory
problems take New York's growth in the
early 20th century as an example
building heights were growing and money
weren't happy with it at the time 5th
Avenue was filled with stately mansions
homes to the wealthy families of New
York like the Carnegie's and
Rockefellers they worried that unless
building heights were restricted 5th
Avenue would turn into a darkening
overshadowed by these towering behemoths
these worries led to the 1916 zoning
resolution which allowed buildings to
grow in height but restricted their
width as they grew this is one of the
primary reasons so many buildings in New
York built during that era tapered
towards their top it was a measure to
prevent buildings from blocking the
sunlight below but the regulation had
loopholes and architects quickly
exploited them between 1916 and 1960 the
city's zoning code was amended 2,500
times the 1961 zoning resolution brought
in strict rules and introduced a new
floor to area ratio rule that restricted
building heights according to the
district they were in the Florida area
ratio said how much floor space could be
built on a plot of land a Florida area
ratio of 2 means you can build a
two-story building on your full
or a four-story building on half your
plot r1 r2 and r3 districts our
low-density zones like Staten Island and
the Jamaica estates and Queens and they
have a Florida area ratio of 0.5
whereas major thoroughfares in Manhattan
are are nine and are ten districts which
have a Florida area ratio of 7.5 and 10
respectively this Florida area ratio
rule for pressure and designers to
allocate more space to open plazas or
other public spaces around the building
that facilitated taller Tower
whereas the 1916 zoning laws resulted in
tiered buildings that started right on
the sidewalk the 1961 zoning code
encouraged privately owned public space
to ease the density and claustrophobia
of a high-rise city I think we can all
agree that that is move in the right
direction zoning regulations like this
are important to prevent brainless
growth that destroy his city's character
but sometimes they are overzealous and
prevent modernization altogether take
Washington DC zoning code that has been
in place for over a hundred years with
little change the height of buildings
Act of 1910 prevents any building beyond
40 meters in height that is incredibly
restrictive and that is resulted in the
city where the tallest structure is a
giant stone obelisk and this thing even
with a relatively small population
washington has some of the worst traffic
in the u.s. a study released this year
by INRIX found that the people of
washington waste an average of 75 hours
per year in traffic that means their
journeys take 75 hours more than if
there was no congestion they were second
only to Los Angeles who waste an average
of 81 hours a year in traffic LA is
often singled out as a key example of
this problem of unchecked out worth
growth it was a key theme in the movie
her where the carrot dominated urban
sprawl of the present is juxtaposed with
a vision of a glossy clean high-rise
future for LA the main character
Theodore lives in a highly developed
downtown LA he lives in a high-rise
building and works in a high-rise
building he is able to walk between them
and Carrie seem to have ceased to exist
he instead uses the extensive metro
system to get around the movie even
designed a futuristic subway map overlay
to create this vision of the future
the producers digitally enhanced the
city's existing skyline while also
mixing in shots from present-day LA with
numerous shots from shanghai pudong
district
like this pedestrian skybridge which
allowed Spike Jonze to film Theodore
wandering through the urban jungle
without having the carrier's at street
level interfering with the illusion of a
city that has transcended the need for
personal transport that transformative
change seems implausible and not likely
in the near future but cities can
undergo metamorphosis when money and
regulations are not an issue take the
mid 19th century renovation of Paris as
an example Paris was once described by
one of its residents as an immense
workshop of purification where misery
pestilence and sickness work in concert
where sunlight and air rarely penetrate
a terrible place where plants shrivel
and perish and where of seven small
infants four died during the course of
the year this is an incredibly stark
description of Paris when present-day
Paris is often fond over for its wide
boulevards amazing architecture an
extensive public transport system Paris
of old was plagued with problems caused
by the outdated planning of its medieval
past Paris was in need of renovation and
Napoleon the third made it possible by
giving the money and power needed to
Baron Haussmann he transformed these
narrow streets and old dilapidated
buildings into spacious boulevards he
revamped all these streets in red and
created two new parks for the city's
residents Napoleon the third and
Houseman helped transform Paris into the
charming City of Light that's 16 million
tourists now visit every year but it may
be time to start rethinking Paris's City
Planning once again the lack of housing
in central Paris has caused prices to
raise so high that only the rich can
afford it
forcing the working-class families of
Paris to the outskirts of the city
creating huge disparity of wealth
between the center and outskirts this
map shows the concentration of social
housing as a percentage of total
residences with the largest percentages
being located furthest from the city
center and even now these people are
being forced further outside the city
limits as gentrification occurs Paris is
no stranger to revolts of the
working-class with notable riots in 1968
2006 and just this year
Paris saw more roads as new labor laws
were passed giving employers more power
to increase working hours decrease
holidays and decrease pay the lack of
affordable housing compounds these
social problems and the main cause of
these prices is Parisians unwillingness
to build over existing building
during Haussmann's renovation of paris
height restrictions on buildings were
raised from sixteen point five to
nineteen meters but the transformation
of Paris took place in a time where
elevators did not exist in 1965 the
height restrictions were lifted and the
Mount Parnassus tower was constructed
soon after a building that is loaded by
Parisians it sticks out from the
surrounding buildings like a sore thumb
there is a fine line between progress
and regression Paris renovated to rid
itself of the claustrophobic narrow
streets of the past building higher
without thought will bring it right back
to that the construction of this
building resulted in the height
restrictions being reduced to 25 meters
for central Paris France is a heavily
regulated country and when its rulers
decide they don't want change change
will not occur but one parrot of Paris
proves that modern high-rise buildings
can be introduced without destroying the
character of the city la défense is
Europe's largest purpose-built
business district housing one hundred
eighty thousand daily workers the
defense proves that skyscrapers can be
incorporated into the historic
background of Paris without destroying
its chair but La défense is a financial
district it was built to create office
space and houses just 25 thousand
permanent residents there is little
motivation to build high-rise buildings
to reduce housing prices as it is
cheaper to push people to the outskirts
of the city Paris is not alone in these
problems London has been criticized for
the same problems and vice news made an
excellent documentary about the effects
of this gentrification of working-class
neighborhoods there is no easy way of
balancing preservation and growth but we
need to put our country's leaders under
more pressure to consider this and not
just follow the cheap easy route because
the problems will only get worse as our
populations grow if we allow those
height restrictions to stop us from
building on 5th Avenue the world would
have been deprived of iconic buildings
like the Empire State and Flatiron
buildings great cities are not static
they constantly change and move with the
times the greatest of our modern cities
like New York and Singapore function
because their height enables a huge
number of people to work and live on a
small piece of land
that is something our world is going to
need going forward as their populations
continue to grow thanks for watching you
may have noticed this video is about
twice as long as my usual videos I want
you to experiment a bit and see how
longer videos do in this channel so
please let me know what you think in the
comments or on Twitter and tell me a bit
about your city and how you would like
to see it change I also want to take
this time to thank my patreon supporters
properly there are a hundred and fifty
four of you supporting this channel on
patreon that is insane you've helped me
buy a new laptop so I can edit quicker a
new microphone to improve my audio among
other things I cannot thank you enough
for supporting and believing in this
channel it means the world to me
if you'd like to see more content or
support real engineering the links from
my patreon Instagram Facebook and
Twitter accounts are below
you